[Music]
quite quickly realized I've always known
that I've never been the best recruiter
like I've never been in a room full of
recruiters and thinking I'm the best
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Oliver Perry a
good recruiter should be able to spend
enough plates managing three four five
six interview processes at one point I
think that's fair it's been a long time
coming he was due to be involved in a
live podcast event which we had to
cancel due to covid so it was really
great to sit down with him finally in
the podcast Booth if they're just like I
think he uh I think he works in a
warehouse or something like if you're
not curious about that what your best
mate does for work there's no chance
you're gonna call some stranger and we
focused on the last four years where
he's gone from being an individual
contributor and progressed all the way
up to sales director for a company
called trust in soda we spoke about a
lot in this episode but more
specifically around leadership how he's
got the most out of the people that he's
worked with how he's managed teams in
sectors that he's never recruited in how
he's really committed to being not the
hero but the hero maker and that
probably explains why he's been voted
several times over the last couple of
years the MVP of the entire company
enjoy the episode Ollie welcome to the
podcast thanks mate thanks for having me
excited to sit down with you like we I
had you booked in for the to remember
the live podcast event pre-covered
yes as a panel oh yeah yeah yeah and
from the shed yeah so you end up having
to do remotely but you was it was you uh
Rhonda d'ambrosio and Chris
um oh no that's gonna kill me that's
that picture's face
it does like oh no that's good enough
yeah that's whoever that is I apps I'm
I'm sorry I just don't remember I should
know who that is but it's been a long
time coming right obviously we've got to
know each other a bit over the the last
couple years so like being honest with
we had on a blow smoke up your ass
immediately but anyone that I speak to
in and around you that will work of you
speak really highly of you specifically
around
you being someone who is an
inspirational leader gets the most out
of people you're a nice guy super smart
so yeah I'm really excited to dig into
this with you so to give everyone some
immediate context we're just saying it's
going to be your ninthian recruitment
September yeah
uh you've worked for two organizations
um for the last nearly four years three
and a half years you've worked at trust
and soda part of the tronovo group and
that's what we're going to be focusing
on today so just to give everyone some
immediate context over the last three
and a half nearly four years you've
progressed
from just looking at your uh LinkedIn
now from Principal consultant all the
way to sales director that is impressive
so that sounds cool and impressive that
does sound cool all the way to sales
director so just to paint a bit of a
picture of what that actually means I
think you shared with me that the most
amount of direct reports that you had at
the highest point was 36 it's around 25
currently not direct but
like fruit like yeah yeah in the team
yeah in the team uh and you you
basically the way you described it was
anything perm related on the solo brand
new is involved in exactly right that's
how you're involved and what that means
is you've got Ireland Germany UK
yeah yeah I don't have Island anymore
since I moved back to London that's main
stayed in Ireland but yeah okay cool and
then uh so basically what that looks
like today is you've got
four billing managers yep that you
manage yeah uh and then you've got
visibility on the profit and loss
control costs triggers to hire I think
what you've had really good exposure to
which you shared to me is really getting
into the nitty-gritty of building a
profitable business not just yeah
recruitment team we're smashing our
Billings Target like there's been a lot
more to it that you've been involved in
and you're responsible for yeah I'm
lucky that it's that's driven by a house
soda and should over operate like they
give you a lot of that um Clarity and on
it because I interviewed a few people as
managers and there's no no for their own
some businesses just don't let you see
that there's another fine number hit it
we'll deal with the rest but actually
soda in a good way give you like the
full clarity on seeing what goes in what
comes out and giving you a chance to
control it so yeah I'm looking at it and
that that's something that you're then
measured on right so I think what you
shared to me please crime if I'm wrong
but what you shared with me was 2022
soda um 5.5
in in revenue and sales yeah that's what
we hit in 2022. yeah I know that was the
perm sales and we did it was the first
year we started selling what we call
embedded hiring Solutions
um we did half a mill of that yeah so
it's about six million total yeah
and I guess find a bit of context
because this is what we want to speak
about is you just like if we were to put
your role into like a pie you said
around 40 of it people leadership
Employee Engagement yeah so one-on-one
meeting reviews internal challenges 20
learning development uh within that as
well then 10 year old forward-looking
strategy for vertical Market strategy
yeah another
um 10 would then be always recruiting
internal recruitment yeah and then I
just realized this doesn't make 100 and
I've got 20 client acquisition to
increase client spend something or you
but a bit a big chunk of it leadership
culture getting the most out of your
people make sure people are happy
they're performing and that's what we're
going to talk a lot about today as well
as what you're seeing from a client
acquisition strategy sense that you'll
find and work within your organization
yeah so let's start with a million pound
question something that you've probably
continued to think long and hard about
as you're building your teams yeah what
are the common characteristics and
traits of current top performers in
recruitment today do you believe
I yeah I'm lying if I just don't start
with with work ethic like it's it's such
a boring answer but
um I'm just such a believer in it like
I'm such a believer that you've never
met you've never had anyone sit here
that hasn't had to work really hard like
it's just you just don't meet people
like that and you'll you'll get the um
you've got the counter argument like the
hustle culture and
um and like quality over quantity like I
get it like quality is really important
but I'm just such a believer that like
quantity leads to Quality like you can't
paint the perfect painting first time
you have to paint 100 pet paintings
you'll get there eventually so yeah work
ethic for me is just is it's really hard
to answer before but like once you find
once you know someone works hard it's a
good trait uh I heard your last podcast
you talked about discipline a lot like
I'm talking about using that word a lot
because
uh motivation for me is kind of an
overused word because it's it's
extrinsic it's external like you expect
something to happen in your environment
to motivate you and that's then hard to
control so discipline way more important
no matter how you feel no matter what's
happening in your environment you're
going to do x y and z
um and then the the third one the quirky
one for me is curiosity so
you can't there is no Playbook to
recruitment there is no they say this
and you say this
um and a lot of how a phone conversation
will go or how like a process will go
will be down to that person's curiosity
of like how they ask what they ask Etc
et cetera hard to teach but I feel like
if you meet curious recruiters they're
usually uh usually High performing um
yeah I really like the The Cure the
Curiosity one yeah I I asked an
interview now one of my interview
questions I'm really bad interview but
I'm trying to get better one of my
interview questions is tell me about it
like tell me about one of your mates
they're like what are you on about and
they're like what give me one of your
mates names and they're like and Adam
I'm like what does Adam do for work tell
me all about his job and it's genuinely
one of my red or green flags I like that
if they're just like oh I think he uh I
think he works in a warehouse or
something like if you're not curious
about like what your best mate does for
work there's no chance you're gonna call
some stranger stranger a Candida and
actually like be inquisitive and curious
about them and what they want to say I
like that yeah it's good I think that's
super practical actually yeah yeah I
actually I really like that
so I want to dig straight into
Ollie the leader
so something that you shared with me in
preparing for this that really resonated
which I think probably explains a lot is
you said to me
don't be the hero be the hero maker
and that resonated with me because
uh you're not going to hear a lot of top
performing recruiters say that I don't
feel like so uh in in the sense that
you've ended up being known from the
people that I speak to around being a
leader a great manager whatever that
that doesn't surprise me that one of
your perspectives you have was what you
really doubled down on when you went on
this leadership Journey was yeah being
the hero maker yeah so like
why why why why why why why was that a
perspective that you started to instill
and and sort of view leadership or
management from that standpoint
quite um quite quickly have realized
I've always known that I was never never
been the best recruiter like I've never
been in a room full of recruiters and
thinking I'm the best from like a
quality or results perspective
um
and then I got lucky enough to like work
with some really good people when I
ended up in the leadership role I'm in
now early days who were way better than
I ever was and all I was thinking is if
if they turn up like motivated engaged
happy to come to work proud that they
work with me with this business like
that's all I've got to do like I've just
got to get them out of bed and be like
I'm excited to go to work and they come
in and like if I get that bit right
because they're so good at their job
like I don't necessarily have to touch
too much else
um so
checking the next situation I don't
think I went in with that mindset but in
this role I ended up working with some
amazing people and then I was like yeah
okay don't flood them don't overall them
but like just make sure they're really
happy and engaged to come to work
because they're so good at their job and
then yeah and then they yeah like they
were a big part of the success of the
last two years
so I was just it's all like get the good
people firing basically so yeah and then
I heard that I heard that phrase after
the fact and I was like I looked
retrospectedly like that I'm gonna I'm
gonna use that yeah so let's talk about
that then for for leaders for playing
managers building managers building
leaders directors whatever if they're
looking at their team right now and
they've probably got because it's
normally how it works 10 of their team
absolutely [__] fire in yeah they're
exceptional they're doing 80 of the
target yeah
what were when you recognized that and
that's where you could add the most
value what were the one two three things
you immediately or work towards doing to
make them look forward to Mondays be
proud to be where they were what were
some of the things that you implemented
did to really get the best out of them
um
I honestly I think it becomes like uh
the first thing is
they're understanding like where they
want to get to you have to do that to
begin with because everything you do
after the fact every single day how you
treat them how you talk to them
you have to be led by what they want so
um
like the personal development plan right
if you haven't done a personal
development plan with one of your like
top forms of everybody but with your top
performers they tell you what they want
they tell you how they want to be
communicated to tell you what their
career goals are etc etc et cetera then
it all works back from that right some
people want praise some people want
um autonomy some people want l d some
people whatever they you have to hear
what they want to treat them as
individuals and get there so that
personal development plan is a bit
really important and how how did you do
that quickly was that a here you go guys
here's a couple of questions think about
them we're going to walk through them
together on yeah Friday yeah basically
we we do it once a year and review it
mid-year basically okay um and it's just
what a series of prompts to say
Blue Sky Thinking it's a bit of Blue Sky
Thinking like one year two year three
year five year stuff
um but it's more it's really more about
how they want to be treated and what
what they feel gets the best out of them
what so what sort of questions are you
asking
um
uh one of one of the I think there's
like four questions on there but what if
we talk about goals and goals being the
end goal and then like the rocket fuel
to get there what is that Rocket Fuel so
you tell me you want to build a million
quid that's a goal like it doesn't that
doesn't really help me get there but
like what is the what is the fuel that I
need to give you daily to reach that
goals and again that that comes down to
communication style that comes down to
recognition that comes down to time so
tell me what you need for me to reach
that goal and that's like one of the
questions one of them is
um how do we maximize death what are
their strengths and how do we maximize
how do I how do you think I maximize
your strength so they may be really
strong in one part of the job and
how do we how do I top that up more and
not worry about necessarily the things
right so yeah this I can't think of the
two questions but there's only four
questions on the personal development
platform but it's very blue sky I think
and it's very like blank piece of paper
and but the aim is to like feel like you
know how to manage them come out of it
so step one before we even get into the
things that I asked you is you need to
[__] know yeah what's important to
them how they want to be treated what
their big aspirations are so we've done
that yeah what were then some of the
things that you approached attempted did
daily weekly yeah that then you know and
maybe even thinking about it now what
are some of those things so let's see
how many Atomic habits quotes I get in
this country by the way because because
when once you once had the goals one of
the one of the things that Rings true to
me from that book is you don't
um you don't rise the level of your
goals you fall to the level of your
system so they tell me this is what I
want and then it's like okay what what
are your systems what happens on a
weekly basis a monthly basis that might
be how much touch time we have together
that might be how much l d time I give
to you how much D time you give to
others it might be uh community-led what
do you do outside of the day job what do
you do in your personal life like what
are your there you go what are your
systems to put that in place and
um yeah you have to if the PDP is just
all Blue Sky Thinking and it's all like
I want to be the well I want to be the
best and then that's it and then you
just put it in the cupboard like it's
rubbish like you have to have the
systems in place and and uh and they can
be different they can be um they can be
things that are in your diary they can
be just things that I need to do on a
regular basis some people want
the stick some people want the carrot
and I kind of need to know what that is
basically so the PDP hopefully should
tell me that and then okay yeah so then
you help uncover what what systems they
have in place yeah
talk about what they have in place and
then it's like well okay well these are
maybe the systems that we need to
improve or need to look at I need to
work on that are going to help you
hopefully arrive at the destination that
you're aiming for yeah exactly it will
always
I don't know I'm quite process driven
and I'll always end up back at the day
job like it'll always end up being like
okay let's talk about your business
intelligence strategy or your
um
your candidate Network or your how you
manage the database I will always end up
back there eventually because they're
the systems that you put in place to
help you reach the goals but um
definitely work that way around
um but some of these people I'm talking
about that's just so fantastic at their
job that actually like they're telling
me like the whole coaching mentality is
me just being like Oh yeah what else
questions and then they they just come
up with the answer so um so yeah it
makes it easier when they're a good job
let me ask you this then hopefully this
comes across the right way oh
uh because I I speak to a lot of high
performance so I think you shared me
your this might just been your best year
I don't know if it was best year ever
you said it was like 250k yeah
I know yeah which now you've got some
people listening podcast thinking what's
he doing now no not at all uh but the
reason why I reference that yeah because
I'm sure you might have had to wrestle
this I don't know I'm assuming here yeah
look I I speak to high performers who
can be uninspired by their leaders
because
they're not better than them yeah
have you had to wrestle that how have
you navigated that because that's why I
think what what makes your story great
is you might I might speak to people
that if you were to go Ollie the
recruiter compared to me the recruiter
yeah I know I'm three times better than
him yeah however I really respect and
value Ollie
um because of his leadership and
management these are some of the things
you're talking about yeah so what yeah
like what are some of the things behind
that because I think that is something
that I hear a lot where I feel like yeah
I'm not learning anything I'm not
inspired by that my leaders and
oftentimes it's that look they're not
willing to take the first step they're
not willing to do what I do and I'm
listening to someone that I know
couldn't do what I do and I know there's
a bit of an ego there but I feel like
that could potentially be something
you've had to wrestle with so true
um you said take the first step
absolutely like the classic I wouldn't
tell them to do anything I wouldn't do
and that is absolutely the case right I
wouldn't jump on I wouldn't not jump on
any call send any email go to any
meeting that uh and not do what I expect
them to and hopefully they all realize
that and they've seen that even if it's
not the quality they would do yeah
actually like
um and and then the the word the first
word that comes to mind is vulnerability
so I feel like it works if you are a
vulnerable leader where you admit your
mistakes and you bring yourself down to
their level because everyone makes
mistakes like I lost a retainer pitch
this week
um it was against one of their agency
and I led the whole thing they went to
the other agency right and actually
telling them why I think I didn't win it
and giving them the feedback the client
gave me that vulnerability I just think
is so important to like get them on your
level so you never feel like
um
you never create that like hierarchy
like even the silly little things like I
hate saying my team and like those don't
mean like it's the team it's not my team
I don't own anybody I don't own anything
that those are like colloquisms but yeah
I think vulnerability is really an
important part that they they don't you
don't create this hierarchy that doesn't
need to be there
um and then a lot of it's just being a
good human most of the time like a lot
of the traits are just being a good
person like you'd want to treat your
family and friends yeah and then the
other the last thing is is l d like I'm
a big believer in
constant Learning and Development and I
hope everybody that's ever worked with
me does think that I would always help
them fine-tune parts of their job right
I would never
ask them to just do more do more do more
like quantity is important but like the
quality of what it is is really
important so hopefully everyone's at
work with me even if they're better than
me in the day job they've always thought
like Ollie can actually teach me
something that I don't know yeah
I really like that now I think that
that's very well well put I guess what
I'd love to dive into and get into a bit
of of detail because I think people will
be interested in that is how how have
you gone about and I'm sure this has
evolved over time but how have you gone
about
structuring your days weeks with a big
part of your role being management
getting the most out of people yeah what
does that typically look like I guess
maybe you could take a snapshot as a
sales director because there's a lot of
moving Parts yeah I don't know if your
your door has literally become
one-on-ones and meetings but yeah how
have you how have you sort of chopped
that up and what does it actually look
like to ensure that you cover all bases
on looking after your people
um you know covering any challenges or
potential challenges down the road
you're also making sure that you send 10
emails out each day for potential
recruiters you're thinking about well
like we're really not pulling as many
jobs as we were yeah three months ago
like what is this yeah what is a typical
Cadence look like for early at the
moment as a sales director have you
chopped that up so I'll um I'll talk to
you from a week I might sound really
boring but um and the purpose of some of
the things so
uh first things first is like you've
you've got the mix of the team meetings
and the one-to-one meetings again I'm a
big believer that team meetings all
about engagement they're all about uh
camaraderie they're all about all
agreeing we're going to do this together
not personal accountability not name and
shame in somebody like
um not trying to create accountability
like a Hisham running team core you're
going to do this for me this week or
whatever right like it's just it's
fruitless right
um toothless
so team meetings are all about like the
bigger picture here's where we are as
team here's where we want to get to
here's where your part's playing that so
team meetings for me are um
on as important as the one to one so you
have your teammates Monday Wednesday
Friday which is all about here here's
where we are the one-to-ones
the the agenda in the follow-up of a
one-to-one I think is just so so so
important I think both sides of the
fence can really underestimate the
importance of it the consultant can come
really underprepared chapter 20 minutes
about the weather last 10 minutes is
like just a real rush through has your
desk looking like those open questions
like how's your desk looking like I hate
it like I want an agenda that has like a
specific closed answer what's your
pipeline what opportunities have you
moved from X days to X days what live
jobs you work in
um like closed closed agenda points that
get followed up every single week so
everybody knows they come to a
one-to-one and all he's going to ask me
these things he's going to help me with
these things and the next time we have a
one-to-one he's gonna hold me
accountable to what I said I did or what
I said I was going to do so that like
one-to-one agenda everyone should know
going to a meeting what the agenda is in
a one-to-one and everyone should know
that it's going to get spoken about
again otherwise you come to a one-to-one
and you're just like let me just get
through this because he's never going to
talk to me again so your team means
one-to-ones
um just on that quick sorry it's a
button sorry because I think I could
improve mine so I'm asking selfishly
yeah what what does that agenda look
like then
um
so we have the the light the live job
agenda is going through your pipeline so
which is live interviews what live
interviews you've got live jobs and then
it's understanding how you can improve
the chance of that
making your money if that's close if
that's you need to do this with the
candidate you need to do this with the
client have you asked that kind of that
question what does wife think what does
her husband think about like those kind
of closing questions on the kind of it's
a live interview make that closer to the
money what can you do in that process do
you need to pre-close the client do they
re are they really going to offer 80k
that they told you three weeks ago they
might offer so the actions off the back
of that then you've got your business
development so we have a very easy sales
funnel which is
um three-stage opportunity so if you
want to nurture an opportunity it's a
it's an open opportunity I've identified
that I want that to work with that
client I want to pull that job
and then you go through your sales
funnel within your multi-channel sales
funnel and if they come back to you in a
negative way it moves to responder so it
moves like the communication's open
clients talk to you they've answered the
phone they've answered an email you're
one step closer but they don't want to
work with you right and then the third
stage of positive response and then part
of the agenda one-to-one is you review
your positive responses like what do we
actually need to do to turn that into a
client in terms your review responded
what do we need to do to turn that
positive invite them to an event send
them to Market Insight send them another
candidate get them on the phone again
whatever it is and then you open ones
you haven't heard back from what you do
with them so those two like live jobs
opportunity funnel there that they're
the main like stay of it we're very data
driven like I don't
um
I don't agree with this like no kpi
policy and recruitment I just don't like
you can't improve what you can't measure
so everyone's got what good looks like
from last week job CVS interviews and
there's might be a couple of inputs like
new business calls or targeted specs we
sell it week on week this is what you
want to do this week and you review it
this week you said you do this you did
you did this like where can you improve
what do you need to do that kind of
thing so they're the three like stages
of agenda I don't know if that's gonna
help you no no no I think because I
think mine I've set agendas but it's
probably more lent to
because what my follow-up question on
that is everything that I've tried to
learn about one-on-ones is it's about
making about Ollie the person you're
sitting down with yeah so not one part
of that
I don't know you might just do this as
your as you throughout the week and in
different moments yeah but that's a very
like that one-to-one I just explained is
like a sales meeting okay fair and then
you have to review one-to-one as in like
minor league so at the moment because I
think this is what a lot of people do
one-on-one I don't know I'd view one a
one-on-one as Ollie talks about how this
week's gone yeah yeah that's a monthly
review for us okay fair that's a monthly
review so not that like you're just a
robot all month until yeah it's a
monthly review but you have to be real I
think you have to be really careful that
you don't Advocate your responsibility
in a sales meeting and to like not help
that person and if and if you're
one-to-ones or uh non-actionable
conversations I just don't think it
helps your reviews for that your reviews
about the person's well-being about the
person's goals motivations
you can do all that in 30 minutes yes
Fair no I I I probably I really rate
that because
what you're also doing there which I
really like as you said this isn't I can
definitely imagine and see it now that I
don't go into that meeting with you and
you're like you haven't done this you
haven't done this your [__] you're not
doing that right you're trying to uh see
opportunities where you can help them
move things closer to uh yeah improve
where they're trying to get to or help
with things but what you're helping
people do which are a lot of recruiters
don't do because I speak to them and
when we provide learning from them and
the uh for them and these things is
you're enabling them to self-reflect and
know where they are every single week
exactly that and a lot of people don't
if you nail that meeting as the manager
you don't have to do much because the
numbers the data the accountability the
action speak for themselves and the
person comes with the answers here's
what I did here's what I didn't do
here's what I want to get better at if
it's really directive it's not a good
sales meeting if I'm like coming over
the top and telling them like everything
they need to do and rather than allowing
them coaching them to get there like
it's a bad time because you're taking
away the overwhelm of going I'm nowhere
[__] in my target yeah and yeah like
how the [__] am I going to get there but
if I'm taking a step back every week and
go I've oh well I've moved five clients
from a non-responder to responded I've
got well I've got five more interviews
than I did last week every single week
I'm checking in so you said follow-up's
really important as well as those what
does that look like is it just you have
to [__] follow up what do you mean
right we've done this week one week two
we're going to talk about and how you
got on is that what you mean the basics
of like putting it into writing like
basically not my memory is terrible and
I and I shouldn't expect you a week
later to remember what we spoke about so
like it just we easy thread in the teams
chat issue I'm gonna one to one okay
here's what we've went through
um this is your last seven days this is
the last 30 days and these are the
actions we want to achieve going into
this week and we go into the next
meeting and it's just there to review
there's no like
I don't know if without the written
follow-up I just think it's so
wishy-washy it's you just relying on
memory and you're relying on emotion a
little bit it's really easy for you as a
manager to Advocate to be like I can't
really remember we spoke about last week
so how was your weekend mate yeah the
sound and then it's like you're you're
just getting yourself a hole so like the
written follow-up is so boring it's so
boring like it's not amazing like
leadership tactics they're doing it yeah
yeah so we've got team meetings one and
ones yeah and there's some quirky things
so we'll do like monthly business
development sessions where
um try and collaborate with what we're
doing like it's really uh it's really
easy for us all to run off and try and
nurture opportunities and speak to this
point of contact here here and here and
this person's over here and here so
every month we'll get together and be
like this is this is what I've done and
it and there's another consultant and
another vertical trying to do the same
thing with another point of contact in
the other business right so just
aligning those two things uh we call it
um opportunity collaboration
um
what else happens in a normal week uh we
do probably an l d session a week
um literally just what is tip of my
tongue like what last week we uh I don't
know we had loads of finals rejected
right so let's just do a quick 30 minute
bite size on uh interview debriefing and
pretty close like what how can we affect
the post interview part of the job
because we've had loads of families
rejected are we closing both sides of
the party so like a lot of the L D's
really in a good way reactive to what's
happening in the here and now
um and yeah then all my upward stuff is
quite uh like to the to the CEO is quite
data driven my plan numbers conversion
profitability forecasting your
profitability you have this amount of
pipeline in the team your average in
converting about this percent when's
that going to be invoiced that you know
you can calculate roughly if you close
these amount of deals 100K invoices
month 100K next month okay next month
what's your profitability forecast
looking like and you said triggers to
higher and that's a really good way of
them making sure okay in the next three
months we're going to be a bit dark
positive by X let's plan triggers to
higher to maximize the like per head
spread of the NFI so that the upward
stuff is all like profit and loss
forecasting which
sounds boring but I used to be an
accountant so I like it yeah that's what
I trained at Union I didn't know that
yeah yeah oh yeah I bet you absolutely
love that stuff I love numbers
so how a big part of uh your role also
then and I know this is also challenges
how have you
approach managing managers
that's the hardest thing why is that so
hard just because you're
I call them the front line like the
front line Soldiers the people the sales
people
um they are your most important asset
right they're they're the people doing
most of the work and I'm now to remove
from them so you're like you don't want
to you don't want to you want to help
them but you don't want to undermine the
manager so I did find it really hard and
what did you find hard about it just
being removed yeah just like get like
trying not to be in the way so
um coming over the top of all they did
they did that maybe they could do that
and actually me being doing that desk
coaching to that person when actually
I'm I'm undermining potentially
undermining the person that manages them
right so just
um accountability is the hardest thing
to say it was like holding somebody
accountable to doing something so hard
and when it's a second removed
accountability hey yes I want you to get
Bob to do that well I think Bob should
do that
um and then in our review your Bob
didn't do that and then it's like the
accountability is water down two ways
and actually get into the bottom of it
it's really hard so that manager
managers is really really hard and as we
know Billy manager is just such a hard
job like I say it's my I've been a
manager all the time like your job is
harder than mine it is hard like there's
there's a loads of elements but their
job is so hard so um how do you try and
make their job easier then
um
yeah good question I'd like to make it
easier how do I make billing managers
jobs easier
um
I
don't know the answer how do I make
billing manager's jobs easier because if
you know it's that difficult I speak to
people all the time they're stressed
they're earning less money if they've
got more responsibility they're having
to deal with other people's [__] yeah I
think the um I think
like coaching them through where they
spend their time is important it's
really easy as a billion manager to
become a parent and it's really easy to
get so invested in like the people side
of it and the modern cuddling and uh and
doing it for them and not coaching them
through it so it's helping them so like
helping them fail a little bit it's
helping them be like it's fine if Bob
goes through a week and doesn't do what
you want them to do as long as the end
of the week is you coaching them to
improve but if if in that week you do
everything for them that's when you
become highly stressed that's when you
lose your time to do your JW and your
day job and actually you're not you're
not like building anything scalable
because you're just spoon feeding them
and they're not gonna be better next
week so helping them through that like
coaching part is is probably the best
you can do
um there's a fine balance between like
autonomy and abandonment so you want to
give them autonomy because they're a
better manager and they're highly
successful it's rather than their job
but you have to be really careful you
don't just like abandon them you're just
like yeah yeah I got it you're fine I'll
see you on Friday let me know you get on
so
um like get giving them that right
balance of time and letting them do what
they need to do is is quite hard
challenge but if you get that right it
really does help Billy managers because
you the last thing they need is someone
breathing down the neck when they've got
all that responsibility hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
saucebreaker because you listen to this
podcast you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products yeah
how have you on this journey so far
because you've had to really get yeah
you've gone on this journey on managing
more of the the P L yeah ebitdoll these
things how has Ollie approached managing
underperformance
uh data driven to be a move like I
um yeah
Performance Management for me has to be
data driven it has to be obvious it has
to be measurable and if it's not then
that's when I think it's really hard to
overcome uh I spoke to I won't name the
names but I spoke to someone in another
business who
um who their model was hired no no
trainees we use higher experienced
people let them do what the hell they
want and we give them the new autonomy
and they were smashing it last two years
and now the Market's down to end and
they don't know how to help them they
don't know what they were doing right
they don't know what they were doing
wrong they have no idea to help these
like really high performers
um so data driven is really important
here here are expectations over a month
a quarter or whatever and it's not just
sales it's inputs like what are the
inputs that you need to do this job to
help you get the results you want so
many different inputs and everyone
should be different no one should just
be a blanket everyone does the same
but then when people are underperforming
it has to be data driven to be like you
have you you haven't done this like you
haven't done this part of the input of
the job and we don't know if you're ever
going to hit the results that you should
up because you didn't do the input so
starting there is really important and
and like being data driven with the with
the actions of underperformance not like
try harder do more do more like analia
yeah
um I'll say that I love it what's it
like what what is Ollie's dashboard do
you know I mean what a like
or just just like because I can imagine
there are some really [__] key things
yeah and you love numbers every day
every week you're looking at that going
oh that's looking good this week like
what's like Ollie's dashboard of the
performance metrics that you're always
keep an eye on yeah that I'm assuming
could act as it lagging indicators of
light right I'm starting to get a sense
that we could potentially going on a
downward trajectory yeah what's that
dashboard what does that dashboard look
like
um so first one is pipeline entries so
pipeline entries pipeline number could
be I've got a hundred thousand pounds
worth of live interviews right
um but it's a number that's um doesn't
always tell the story because you could
have two fifty thousand pound processors
and that's quite fragile and you had two
rejections and you're down to zero so
the total value is not necessarily the
important is the amount of Entry so I
have four live interview processes going
on we we reckon Forge The Sweet Spot
five five good six exceptional so you've
got like effectively six different jobs
with live interviews out so they're
potentially six placements right you get
to that one two and your your pipeline
comes how many pipeline entries have you
got is one liking indicator job CVS and
interviews is everyone's got that
lagging indicator how many jobs you need
to work a month how many CVS need to
send how many first interviews you need
to get so everyone in the business has
that unique to them depending on their
market and their level but they're the
three they're the three like result
dials if you're getting the job CVS and
interviews like you back yourself with
the quality of the work together the
inputs but before that
Canada course is one like again someone
might call me old school but candidate
is king and queen like especially in the
downturn market when when we were
booming the last two years every like a
lot of information was inbound or the
online information that you could turn
into money now the information you turn
into money is what you get from
candidates just the fact like where they
work
um interview leads like uh they're the
product that you sell so finding more
good product that you sell Etc the
candidate King Green how many can you
speak to a week through liking indicator
new business calls how many how I
managers you speak to and then we have
how many targeted specs you send out in
a week so not like I've just sent 30
people this random mass email but I have
email tissue and say hey yes um I know
this about you this is how I could help
whatever Target is back email
um and then the other one that we might
use is opportunities so we talked about
the opportunity sales funnel how many
are you adding into your sales for how
many opportunities you identifying that
you put in the top of your sales funnel
that you then start using your Cadence
and your sequence to get through to win
so they're the
500 trees job CVS interviews time to
calls new business calls targeted specs
opportunities
I really like the pipeline entry one
yeah it's quite new actually yeah we we
always use the pipeline number a lot and
it yeah no you're completely right
because on the face of it it's like wow
200 Grand could drop in yeah yeah but
then when you learn oh that's literally
two jobs so that if both of them don't
go through exactly [__] super
vulnerable and you should be able to
spin and like I don't I don't know what
the magic number is but in terms of good
recruiters should be able to spend
enough plates managing three four five
six interview processors at one point I
think that's fair yeah that's fair I
really like that
um what what I was going to say I guess
this might be it so we've just spoken
about dashboards importance of data and
I think I could that really Rings true
what you were saying with the person
that you spoke to in the company that
you won't name I literally spoke to a
company today where I think it's all we
spoke about this live event didn't we
where it's almost gone too much the
other way on kpis yeah yeah and I think
the language that I like to use is just
science to success like people want to
know or have a better idea because
recruitment there are can be a lot of
particularly fuel 360 that you can be
overwhelmed very easily yeah definitely
so being able to sit with my manager and
you can help me understand and see
through all the spinning plates and like
what good looks like and if I do get in
and around here that should mean that I
end up where I want to yeah it's really
[__] helpful and important yeah and
like you said you can't improve things
that you don't measure Alex uh Alex put
it in a really good way on the on that
podcast Alex Elliot yeah and he was like
if you don't believe in kpis kpi is a
horrible word but wagon looks like spell
if you don't believe in what it looks
like it's like you don't believe in
cause and effect like you don't believe
that doing something leads to something
else like just in life like yeah and if
every hole we have to believe in cause
and effect so yeah
yeah and so like I do think that's
something that people will be wrestling
with particularly people hybrid
environments nothing in the office as
much these things and the reason why I'm
bringing that up is because I guess it
builds on to what he was talking about I
was just curious to get your thoughts on
you've got the data you know what things
should look like how have you then gone
about maintaining standards and is that
through your one-on-ones is that for
your team meetings like how has only
like you can see where things should be
yeah they're not how are you then trying
to influence those things without
stepping on people's toes just telling
people to do moral things
it's in people's standards
it's hard
and the first step we had to take was
the communication of that because in the
downturn in the market downturn
people did have to people do have to do
more right but
and what I mean by that is make an extra
X plus 10 calls to get that job or send
an extra X targeted specs to get that
job or send more CVS to convert because
the candidates are more risk-averse now
and clients more risk of it so people do
have to do more on a downturn but the
communication of that to start with is
really important and hopefully people in
soda believe me but it's not me asking
you to do more it's not uh the boss
asking you to do more it's the market
asking you to do more it's just the
conditions we're in we're in we're now
playing a game where there's just more
moves to make to get to the end of the
game so if we all agree on that we all
agree that if we want to be successful
in the commission hit our targets we do
have to do more like not a not a not a
kpi micro management I just want you to
do more for the sake like we have to do
more it's harder and if if that
communication was rolled out hopefully
as well as I hope it was then that's the
first step so they believe why they need
to do more
and then
um then it comes down to the quality
piece like it's like the basics of the
job resourcing candidate coil job coil
interview prep and DBS those Basics are
the job they're sometimes really easy to
be like
let's just do more and actually like we
convert 20 of pipeline 30 when it's good
we're getting down to 15 at the moment
because like planting candidates a risk
averse and there's so much waste there
and actually like let's just do let's
just make sure we're always doing it the
best as possible like make sure the
candidate qualification call if you some
people just presume they do them
perfectly but actually you do need to
refresh yourself like what is a good one
like in terms of what you get out of it
interview prep and debrief like the
quality of that is really important so
yeah in terms of how it maintains
standards let's just make sure we all
agree why we need to do more let's get
on the same page and let's not put
quality to the side let's not let's not
forget that like the fine-tuning all the
parts of the recruitment process will
also help us be better rather than just
doing more if that makes sense so you
know that that does like what I mean it
comes to my head because this is
something that I'm really trying to be
disciplined with myself because I
totally buy into just like what you've
spoken about today and the way you've
operated things uh whether you've spoken
about how you're operating things is you
definitely have processes and you review
what's working and you're measuring and
you've got the data points to back up
certain things a lot of recruitment
teams one don't don't measure anything
so that this is even more difficult for
them yeah
so like how do you prevent because this
comes into it like how do you prevent
people
being gravitated towards the new shiny
thing in fact personal branding if
that's sequencing or whatever and really
get people to buy into the stuff which
is the same because even if they just do
the same thing and do it better yeah
they'll probably hit their target and
more yeah that that's actually the the
hard thing like because you know we're
building a training business honestly
one of the most common feedbacks that we
get is yeah like really enjoying what
I'm learning
um but a lot of it is the same I'm like
that's a [__] good thing yeah yeah
yeah but that doesn't you you you're
trying you when you're learning it's
almost like you want you want to learn
new I new things and all that but
actually it's come back to what you're
saying just become commit to becoming
world [__] class at those Basics and
just do them every day yes but that
isn't exciting that isn't sexy I want to
know about personal branding I don't
know automating my [__] subject lines
and like do you know what I mean yeah
you probably have to get people away
from the shiny object yeah I saw a ban
at your event um from The Source world I
think it's a great product I had a demo
I think it's a great product it just
makes me feel really sorry for
candidates and clients because they must
be getting bombarded something right now
do I mean just because it's easy to
automate all that stuff but
um going back to your question uh how do
I get them to do the basics it's like
that's what you said is really key so
how do you get your because I'm sure a
lot of leaders can relate to that they
know it they've been in a game for a
while how do you get people excited
about re-looking at that candidate
qualification call and trying to get
them to buy into like look if we do this
one percent better you're gonna hit your
target yeah another Atomic habit quote
the biggest threat to success isn't
failure it's boredom like it's just like
like you say if you get bored of doing
the basics and recruitment that's that's
you'll get yeah so how do I get people
excited about the basics
um
uh
uh leading leading from the front is
probably the first thing like if I'm not
doing the basics of whatever my job is
if I'm not doing the basics on on repeat
um and they don't see me doing the
basics why should they do the basics
right our Basics might be different but
like if I'm not doing them why should
they do them take you back to l d a
little bit as well not just presuming
that they know the best way to do the
basics and let's just refine let's just
retune all of those little things how
you ask those open questions on the kind
of qualification call how you best
prepare candidate for interview let's
just keep fine-tuning those things I'm
really lucky soldiers got an amazing lnd
function this is outside of me that will
do that as well but from like a sales
leadership perspective you want to help
um
plus like celebrating the wins is a
really important one so like when
somebody does
succeed by doing the basics everyone's
got to know about it when someone fills
a job by and the candidate came from
a LinkedIn job application Basics do you
advertise all your jobs some people
don't like some people don't mind mind
boggles right some people just some
parts of the basics are they just forget
to advertise their job but they just
don't deem it important for example when
someone fails a job because someone
applied to that job celebrate it basic
celebrate it like getting interview
leads from a candidate and turning that
into a job celebrate it like I think
that's probably the I think that's
probably the best thing you can do is
just make noise about the success that
the basics are bringing to make everyone
hyper aware of why we're doing it so and
then a lot of the rest of it's intrinsic
a lot of it is about their discipline
and are they are they are they
disciplined enough to do the basics
um
which is a bit harder to to affect
somebody's intrinsic behaviors but so
before we finish them let's talk about
because part of that pie that you're
involved in is the the business
development element yeah spoke a lot
about that the live podcast event didn't
we so yeah yeah what what what's top of
mind what you doubled up what are you
doubling down on at the moment because
as as you said you're having to
communicate to people you're having to
put more
uh in yeah more inputs to to get maybe
what you would have got six 12 months
ago with less inputs what are you
doubling down on
um what are we talking about business
development we're talking a lot about
follow-up simple boring but obvious like
can't expect to do something once and
for it to happen multiple multi-channel
touch points phone email LinkedIn video
we're not very good at video but like
there's many different ways to contact
somebody how many different ways you're
doing it how often are you doing it
follow-up's really important the
strategy before the execution's really
important in business development
everyone's got something different but
if your business development plan is
just
I'm going to ring load of numbers or I'm
trying to well like there is no strategy
behind the execution you're off to a bad
start or opportunity funnel helps with
that a little bit it's like these
there's a reason why they're here and
this is what I'm going to do with them
um helping people with that strategy why
are you contacting those people is is is
business development in general looking
backwards we talk about a lot like it's
really it's really easy to be like I
need to add new companies I need to find
the next uh highly funded uh business I
need to a new new new new sometimes just
turn around look at your database look
backwards and think about all the people
you've ever engaged with all the people
you've spoken to Matt work for there is
business there probably lower hanging
fruit so let's make sure we Look
Backwards before always like looking for
something new
um and yeah I'm just a big believer
about phone based sales like I'm just a
massive believer that has to be
incorporated and how often you speak to
people how can you build rapport build
relationships and I text one of my
colleagues before I came here because he
sent me this start age scope really
resonates with me so when when you share
information with someone I think they
measure it in in a bit I think it's
called and uh basically I think an email
has like 5 000 bits of information in it
I don't know the science behind it
um
and effectively when you talk for one
second you give the other person 20 000
bits of information so you think the
words the tone the body language
whatever
basically like a quarter of a second of
being on the phone you're there's more
information being passed than four
emails right so think about you on the
phone for a minute I think I've only
emails that is to actually pass that
information so I'm just a big believer
in phone based sales that's just not how
are you driving that because I do think
that is that's so common you heard me
talk about on and I've been found I have
a small team of three people and like I
even find it hard to like drive it I'm
like I'm just like uh like if I was in
your shoes I'd probably just call them
because you'd probably get to where you
want to or understand what you need to
understand quickly yeah but it's up to
you but how how are you driving that
with your people because it's so easy
like I don't know if you back in the day
you just strap the phone to their head
not do that because I I don't know what
sort of things you come across but like
something that um I come across the
momentum would be yes don't really like
the idea of like disrupting their day
and I'm like right and then I'll try and
communicate and educate on like well
this is why I wouldn't view it like that
but like how are you driving because if
that's something that I I believe has
become a competitive Advantage from all
the recruitment leaders I'm speaking to
if you're willing to work hard pick up
the phone build those relations it's
about building those relationships that
you just said you're able to build it
more quickly if you're able to have
those interactions not just through a
screen how are you trying how are you
trying to drive that because I'm sure
you get pushback on that yeah
um
not to be too brutal but that kind of
pushback is probably the kind of
pushback you just mentioned in terms of
not enjoying that part of the job
probably goes back to like a hiring
process problem right because you want
to be hiring people that enjoy being on
the phone from like in terms of how we
operate right so but if if let's say
everybody is engaged enough to do it and
has the skill to do it for me it's just
about removing as much friction
to from to make it happen like a lot of
people find it hard I believe because
they their process is so bad that it
takes them like five minutes in between
each call like research development
what's the number do I have the number
click here
so we've got uh very love love my CRM so
it has like the CRM is the most
important thing right okay so we have
it's set up in a way that we have two
functionalities we create two lists
everyone should have sorry everyone
should have yeah two left we call one
the money list
but fine
yeah I need to change that but the money
left for me is you have put a person in
that list that you know there's a reason
why you want to speak to them and you
know you have a mobile number for them
okay right whatever that reason is
that's up to you what could it be it
could be there someone that you used to
work with that's just moved jobs okay it
could be there's a CTO of your target
client could be whatever tunnel
acquisition she lives down the road
she's your neighbor you've got to know
what the reason is if I close my eyes
and I just clicked and dialed through
these numbers and someone answered I
know I know about I know I'm in a
worthwhile conversation because what
happens if people don't have that list
they scroll through should I call them I
don't know next one but to get to that
list there's a lot of preparation so you
we are research and development lists
would be going into the database slice
and dicing the information and going
through and who's going in that list
right so you'd search by whatever people
you work with in the past Target
companies are using like mobile scraping
tools to get all that kind of stuff you
have your big research and development
list and when you identify someone I
want to speak to them they're going to
there and then when you're doing phone
based sales Parkinson's law start time
and time I'm going to do phone based
sales you're just clicking and clicking
and Diving the friction remove all the
friction and then you're not thinking
about anything else but like what I'm
gonna say when they answer the phone
what I'm gonna say you call the profiles
up you've got the history of why you're
calling them you're prepared you've got
your script whatever it is right just
remove that friction and just feel like
you click click click click click like I
don't know sounds
so I'm simply want to say like that but
that's why I think the phone based sales
are so hard because people create so
much friction they're not prepared to do
it and it's so laborious but if if I
just gave you a list of 100 numbers here
and you know if any of the man said it'd
be a call you're excited about it
becomes a lot easier for an activity so
no no that makes complete sense and what
I also like about that is because you
are batching it or trying to encourage
people to do that I think what also can
cause friction is if Ollie hasn't done
phone calls for a bit or you haven't got
recent reps in that makes you more
anxious about and that makes you just
push it a bit like yeah do that late and
then because you do because when you do
when you start calling and you speak to
people you're getting a flight yeah like
you're you're yeah you make sure we all
do it together which I think is
important like we all do it together I
will do it we have a sales Sprint like
when we do it together and people are
expected to not just do it in a Sprint
like it should be happening it should
happen throughout the week but like
let's make sure we have time while we're
doing it together we win together we
fail together we all hear the good the
bad the ugly that's really important I
think is um and yeah we're back in the
office
um three days a week now and I think
that's really helping like not doing
that from your bedroom is it anything
just quickly is there anything that
you've recently tweaked or done as a
team on the phone side that's been
effective that's helped whether it be
the way you've approached the why of
your calling opening your calls or that
anything that Springs to mind in terms
of
that's recently been working or anything
like that there's a few people trial in
the like uh permission based opening
sales call where it's like uh this is a
sales call you've got 30 seconds like
the most hated sales that Benjamin yeah
like he's a it kind of works that it's
not it's not for me I to be honest
there's
um the best sales calls are the ones
that you know something that connects
the person you're on the phone to right
so if that if that money left anything
new name tonight is that money list is
good enough when I call you hey Hisham
yeah we both know Bob or we met at this
event or actually work with you so if if
you've got that bit of information to
start with that makes the sales call a
lot easier for my perspective our value
proposition as a recruitment company is
being community-led so we always have
the ability to
give them something without asking for
something give them a platform to come
on our podcast give them a platform to
come to an event give them a platform to
host an event so we always have that
ability to include down our sales call
um
but yeah nothing nothing too shiny and
wacky outside of those things to be
honest well we're excited about I'm
excited about
I tell you what we're going to look back
at the end of this year
in the world of recruitment and we're
gonna like we're gonna have learned
something we're gonna we're gonna be so
grateful for the harder times and what
we've learned and upskilling ourselves
and parts of the job like I'm I'm
looking forward to
the rest of the challenge this year yeah
yeah what's been the most challenging so
far then this year
um
the job
the job that we would do in over the
last two years in Tech recruitment
you've probably got guests thinking
what's going on about but in Tech
recruitment the job we're doing last two
years was a different job like it was a
different job like it's like asking
someone to be a teacher and now I'm
asking them to be a butcher like there's
a lot of skill sets that was just so
different like what I'm asking someone
to do now to what I was doing two years
ago and what a lot of people will say
they're listening and being like Oh
everyone should have been doing BD all
the time like it should never have
stopped that I I don't necessarily agree
with that controversial on the basis
that you maximize the environment you're
in wherever you are and you adapt
accordingly right the time high volume
high potential you feel every job you
get you maximize every client you're
working with yes climate position is
important but like the skill that people
needed then was a different skill that
they need now so like it's it's it's
it's it's the teaching or getting people
in that mindset of like it's fine we're
all in a different job different
landscape different environment but
we're going to do it together and this
is how we're going to do it I'm going to
fail together so
um so yeah that's that's that's the
challenging part at the moment we're
just doing something potentially
different than we would do two years ago
or 18 months ago Ollie it's been a
pleasure thanks mate thank you so much
for listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode